hi I'm Jessica Clemens and if you're a  horror Thriller head like me then you  should go head over to HBO Max to go  watch the menu star and Ray finds  Nicholas Holt and Anya Taylor joy in  this movie Lily and the character keeps  sending back her broken Emulsion or just  critiquing it more so and they keep  bringing her bigger bigger portions of  broken emotions in actuality they ended  up waterboarding her with the broken  Emulsion in the movie you don't see it  though and it's because they've edited  it out because it was too harsh and  aggressive this was all said by Betsy  coach the producer at the Beyond Fest  Premiere that I was at the next time you  watch this movie even if it's tonight  keep that in mind and remember what it  would probably be like to be  waterboarded by a broken emulsion